it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week xbox 360 owners get a big
smile on their face as they get to join
the titanfall battlefield and confirm
that life is actually better with a
Titan unless you're ripped from your
Titan like the heart of that guy from
the temple of doom but it's actually
still fun even when that happens start
parkouring april eighth
also this week all your sports fantasies
come true with kinect sports rivals or k
srs kids are calling it play tennis with
your favorite stereotyped stock
characters including that battle-ax boss
lady a generic geek character the male
protagonist the Russian lady nobody can
understand and the hooker with a heart
of gold no wait that's the aggressive
coach that doesn't take no crap from
nobody starch water sizing april eight
put your grown-up patch off now the
third episode for the wolf among us
comes out this week but even the trailer
has spoilers so I'm afraid to show it
instead here's baby wolf with the baby
bear for most of you it comes out on
april eighth but if you're playing it on
the xbox just avoid the internet all day
you get it on the 9th also this week you
get war yeah lots and lots of sweet
sweet war warlock to the exiled comes
out so you can explore expand exploit
and exterminate all those giant turtle
monsters and bear monsters and skeleton
monsters and monster monsters and robots
cuz why not robots and what the [ __ ] is
that get into the hex to see April 10
and finally you get to go back to me
Nava as persona 4 comes to ps3 as a ps2
classic originally released in 2009 the
cult hit JRPG is basically degrassi with
a supernatural murder mystery the story
revolves around a group of teens
struggling with the pressures of growing
up while simultaneously trying to
unravel a murder mystery involving
television between the terrific
storytelling and in-depth dungeon
crawling you're not going to want to
pass this up switch to the midnight
channel april eighth oh yeah before i
forget there's another lego game this
one's the hobbit I'm looking for someone
to share in an adventure
what no no we do not want any adventures
here good morning for further details
visit gamespot's new releases page
release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change see
you next week